unlike the rest of us you have a real
job you ABC White House correspondent I
used to be an ABC what I'm afraid to say
that is a real honest-to-god serious job
the one I have now also on yes yes it is
it is but I'm just saying that you have
real credentials you've done some real
things what's it like when you're
covering the White House how much access
do you get when you were the AVC White
House correspondent and we it was it was
frustrating at times because you don't
get to ask the president you don't get
as much access although people who
haven't been to the White House it's
when you go there for the first time
it's really small and actually like the
West Wing is not far from the press room
that you see and you do sometimes you
can bump into people so you don't often
have access to them but maybe if you're
going up to the press secretary's office
you can bump into some I bumped into
Hillary Clinton right after she became
Secretary of State really it's that kind
of thing where you can just like she's
just going to the vending machine and
you're going this way and you you bump
into her I bumped into her and I said
senator Clinton how you doing oh I'm
sorry senator Clinton you're Secretary
Clinton now because I'm an idiot and and
I said Oh which to which you know just
trying to ask her a question which do
you prefer Secretary Clinton or senator
Clinton and she said well I prefer
either one to what we call you when
you're not around what was that about
it's a sick Clinton burn yeah and then
she dropped her mic and walked off the
stage
there's like a wing-walker yeah going
down tapper wasn't that a great clip
subscribe to my youtube channel for an
endless supply of me
[Laughter]